stephen  what are you are you like living inside  of me it's a little more complicated  than that  mark you look different  [Music]  we protect the vulnerable  and deliver justice  [Music]  this is the best worst day of my life  marvel studios moon night only on disney  plus  steven  you weren't supposed to see any of this  what are you you sure you want to know  [Music]  i can't tell the difference  between my waking life and dreams  [Applause]  [Music]  am i like some sort of secret agent  it's a little more complicated than that  marvel studios moon night only on disney  plus  i can't tell the difference  between my waking life  and dreams day and night  it must be very difficult  the voice  this chaos  embrace it  night  you